You know,
I can use a biological example too,
which would place me outside of the
postmodern realm of argument because the
postmodernists don't
believe in biology but,
but they act like they
do cause they all die.
So,
so,
uh,
this primatologist named,
well,
I'll tell you two stories.
Okay.
Cause these are,
these are really useful.
So the ones about rats,
and I got this story from Jaak
Panksepp who is a great neuroscientist.
He wrote a book called
affective neuroscience,
which by the way is on my reading list.
It's on my website.
It's a really good book
affect of neuroscience.
He's a great scientist.
He was one of the people who he learned
that he learned that rats laugh.
They laugh out ultrasonically like bat.
So if you're going to,
you tickle them with a pencil eraser,
they laugh,
but you have to record it and then slow
it down and then you can hear them and
you might think,
well rats laugh like who've
whopping daad grant for that?
What kind of idiocy is that?
It's like,
no,
no.
Just don't,
don't,
don't get ahead of yourself here.
You know,
he was showing that,
that that capacity for social interaction,
for social interaction that was mediated
by physiological touch activated the
same,
excuse me,
activated the same circuits in rats,
that it doesn't people and that
those are actual biological circuits.
And we share them even with rats.
Now,
rats are quite similar to human beings.
As it turns out,
I could say especially postmodernists,
but I won't.
And uh,
and,
and so the fact that that,
you know,
that little routes giggle when you
tickle them is actually extraordinarily
important.
He also identified
surprising,
I've been talking too much lately.
Um,
he also identified the primary
place circuit and mammals.
And that's a big deal too
from a scientific perspective.
That's like discovering a new continent,
like discovering a whole brain system
that people really didn't know existed.
That's a big deal.
So here's a little story about rats.
Young rats like to engage
in rough and tumble play,
especially juvenile males.
It's also the case for puppies.
If you've ever had a puppy,
dogs are like that.
They liked to wrestle.
And it's one of the things that he may,
all human beings tend to
do with their offspring.
And it's a really,
really good thing,
like rough and tumble play with children
really helps socialize them because it
helps them figure out the difference
between a touch and even rough touch and
pain.
You know?
Cause one of the things you're doing
when you're rough and tumble playing with
the little kid is,
you know,
you throw them up in the air
and you're wrestling around.
I built my,
I had two couches when my kids were
little that were sort of face to face.
So we built this little wrestling ring
and I used to go in there and pound them
half to death every night,
you know,
so they loved that.
I mean they get so excited about that.
They love that so much.
It's crazy.
But the reason for that is like you're
stretching out their bodies and you're
showing them that they can't put their
thumb in your eye and you're teaching
them to be graceful and,
and,
and you're teaching them the difference
between something new that's happening
to the body and something painful.
You're really teaching them to dance.
And it's this really
complicated physiological dance
that that is indicative of
a socialized being.
And that's partly why women like
men who can dance by the way,
um,
because it shows that you can
pay attention to someone else,
first of all,
that you're coordinated.
But even more importantly that you can
take the fact of your coordination and
coordinate that with
someone else's coordination.
So,
and that's very primal and physiological.
It's built right into your body and rough
and tumble play helps with that a lot.
Um,
anyways,
rats also liked to rough and tumble play
for much the same reasons and sort of
sort of pretty much all social mammals.
So you can tell that rats like it.
See,
how do you know if a rat like something?
Well,
he'll work for it.
And one of the ways you can figure out
if a rep wants to work for something is
that,
you know,
you get them in a state where maybe he's
desperate for whatever he's working for
and you can put a little spring on them
and figure out how hard he pulls to go
somewhere.
He knows where he's going to get that.
And then you can measure the force that
he's willing to apply in that gives you
a rough estimate of his motivation.
Or maybe ask a bar,
press like,
uh,
you know,
like a coke,
cocaine addicted rat to,
to receive the reward.
And you can count rate of bar pressing
and you can get an estimate of how
excited the route is to go do whatever
it is the route's going to do.
And so Panksepp used to,
uh,
put rats,
it pair them one riot against the
other and kind of a play a Rina,
not a very big thing.
And uh,
and these were juvenile males
and they would work to do that.
Okay.
So they liked it.
And then maybe one rat was
10% bigger than the other.
And then when you paired them,
the big rat would beat the little route
because 10% weight advantage was enough
to make the bigger rat dominant.
Okay.
So then they established basically
dominance and submission.
You might think about that
as a power relationship.
And to some degree it is.
But it's more complicated than that.
And this is very important.
So,
so the rats play together once and the
a big rep pins the little route really
very much like wrestling rats
wrestle just like people wrestle.
Um,
and if you pair them together,
then the big wrap can pin the little rat.
Okay,
so now you got dominant rats,
subordinate rat,
roughly speaking and,
but then you see,
if you stop the experiment there,
you'd think,
well the rats play to establish
dominance and submission.
But the thing is is that
rats don't just play once,
they play many,
many,
many times.
And that's also the case with human
beings is that you don't just play once,
you play many,
many times.
And there is a difference between the
rules of a game and the rules of a set of
games.
And that's so unbelievably important.
So you keep that in mind
cause we'll return to that.
So anyways,
the time the two routes get together,
the little rat house to house,
the big route to play because the rule
basically is subordinate entity asks
dominant entity to play.
And so the little rat does
what mammals do to play.
You know,
they kind of put their paws down and
put the rear end up bit up in the air.
You see dogs do that.
And unless you're completely clueless,
you know that that doesn't mean
he's going for your throat.
It means he wants you to whack them on
the side of the head so he can sort of
pretend to bite you.
You know,
it's,
it's pretty obvious if you've
played with dogs and children.
So,
um,
yeah.
And I make that comparison because dogs
and children and understand each other,
right?
They're pack animals,
they follow the same basic rules.
They know how to play.
They can become friends,
otherwise he wouldn't have them as pets.
I mean the dog's not the children.
Um,
so anyways,
the little rat ass,
the big role to play in big rep things.
Yeah.
Okay.
That will play.
They wrestle and you
pair them multiple times.
Well if you pair them multiple times,
what you find is that less the big rat
lets the little rat win 30% of the time
the little rat won't ask
the big rat to play anymore.
And that you think,
well who cares what?
Like why is that important?
It's like,
it's really important.
That's a really important discovery
because it shows you that the,
that even rats have a set set a sense of
fair play that emerges across iterated
games.
It's,
it's,
it's an,
it's evidence for the biological
instantiation of a social morality.
It's a big deal,
man.
That's a big discovery.
And,
and it shows you that
even at the level of rats,
they're very social animals by the way.
Um,
the interactions between rats,
her are mediated by something like
a sense of fairness or justice.
And so that's extremely cool because,
you know,
we tend to think of animals as
having dominance hierarchies.
And that's predicated on power.
And that idea,
even though the bloody postmodernists
don't believe in biology,
they extend that analogy
up to human beings.
It's just not true.